اكدت واشنطن ان القمه الامريكيه اليابانيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه في منتجع ليست مواجهه ضد
اي ضد اي دوله وان هدفها تعزيز الاستقرار
والامن الاقليميين من جانبها دعت بيجين في
تعليقها على القمه التي تعتبر الاولى من
نوعها ويعتقد انها ذات الصله بسياسه الصين
وكوريا الشماليه لعدم تحويل منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ الى ساحه منافسه جيوس
سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات من رسائل التي تريد
قمه كام ديفيد توجيهها وما مدى دقه حديث
واشنطن عن انها لا تستهدف دوله محدده وما
مغزى الانزعاج الصيني من هذه القمه ثم ما
الحسابات التي تحكم علاقه واشنطن وحلفائها
في منطقه المحيطين الهادئ والهندي ببيجيم
وبقيه منافسيهم في المنطقه وما مدى نجاح
الولايات المتحده في تحيه الصين من حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا ثم نتساءل عن المسارات
التي يمكن ان ياخذها الاستقرار في منطقه
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي على ضوء هذه
القمه
وموقف خصوم واشنطن منها وارتفاعها وتيره
الانشطه العسكريه في بحر الصين
[موسيقى]
من اجل تعزيز امنها واضاف انه يتطلع لنقاش
صريح من اجل اعلان حقبه جديده من الشراكه
الصين التي قال السفير الامريكي في طوكيو
ان القمه بالضبط ما كانت تامل في ان لا
يحدث وان رساله القمه هي ان بامكان حلفاء
واشنطن الاعتماد عليها دعت في معرض
التعليق على قمه الى عدم تحويل منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ الى ساحه منافسه جيوسيه
بحسب قولها كما اضافت ان محاوله حشد
الدوائر وخلق التكتلات العسكريه ستثير
بالتاكيد يقظه ومعارضه دول المنطقه وفق
تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور ادوارد جوزيف استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جونس هوبكنز ومن بيجين
فيكتور جاو رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بكم وابدا بضيفي الدكتور خليل
العناني وهذا العنوان لهذه القمه واشنطن
تقول بان قمه كامب ديفيد ليست موجهه ضد
دوله بعينها كان هناك حديث في الايام
الماضي ان هناك حرص من قبل الوفدين
الكوريه الجنوبي وكذلك الياباني على صيغه
ما سيتضمنه البيان الختامي لهذه القمه
الصيغه يظهر بها اسم الصين تحديدا او
كوريا الشماليه في هذا البيان فهل لهذه
الحسابات علاقه بهذا العنوان قمه ولكنها
ليست موجهه ضد دوله بعينها كما تقول
واشنطن
لا اعتقد ذلك على الاطلاق اذا اخترنا نضع
عنوان لهذه القمه قد نسميها قمه النيتو
الاسيوي او على الاقل نواه جديده لابنته
الاسيوي نحن ازاء تدشين لتحالف ثلاثي
دفاعي لاول مره بين ثلاثه دول هي امريكا
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
وفي اغلب الاحوال كان هناك تحالفات ثنائيه
بين كلا الدولتين وبين امريكا نتيجه لوجود
خلافات تاريخيه بينهما خاصه بعد احتلال
اليابان لكوريا الجنوبيه لاكثر من ثلاثه
عقود بين الحربين العالميتين وبالتالي نحن
ازاء تحالف دفاعي ثلاثي جديد قد يكون نواه
بشكل او باخر لتشكيل منظومه دفاعيه في
منطقه شرق اسيا بالقطع هدفها الرئيسي اولا
هو احتواء الصين بشكل او باخر خاصه في ظل
الصعود الصيني سواء كان صعودا اقتصاديا او
عسكريا او امنيا او استراتيجيا الامر
الثاني هو ردع كوريا الشماليه خاصه في ظل
ما نراه على مدار الشغل المرضيه من
المناورات واستخدام الصواريخ البلاستيكيه
وكذلك تجارب النوويه وهذه يمثل الحد بعيد
تهديد لاكبر جرتين وهما كوريا الجنوبيه
وكذلك اليابان الامر الثالث متعلق ايضا
بمواجهه مقادير يبدو تحالفا ثلاثيا مقابل
لذلك هو التحالف الصيني الروسي مع كوريا
الشماليه وبالتالي قطعا الحاضر الغائب في
هذه القمه هو الصين ثم كوريا الشماليه
وهذا يعتبر في رايي الشخصي تحول نوعي في
التوازنات الاستراتيجيه من العالم خاصه في
ظل وجود توترات وتشاحنات صينيه امريكيه
سواء جزء منها متعلق بتايوان جزء منها
متعلق بوجود قوات عسكريه امريكيه نعلم
جميعا انه امريكا لديها على الاقل 80 الف
جندي في تلك المنطقه من العالم حول 30,000
جندي في اليابان 50,000 جندي في كوريا
الجنوبيه وهذا يعتبر منطقه نفوز امريكي
هذا التحالف الذي سيتم الان عنه اليوم هو
في رايي الشخصي تحول نوعي في موازين قد
يؤدي الى توترات اخرى مع الصين في المرحله
المقبله تحول نوعي كما وصفته دكتور خليل
هنا الدكتور ادوارد جوزيف قمه وصفت بانها
تؤسس لعهد جديد وبالتالي
ما الرساله ومضمون هذه الرساله المباشره
وموجهه لمن بالتحديد
بالتاكيد فعلا هذه حقبه جديده ويمكن نسمي
هذه القمه قمه تاريخيه وهي لانها كذلك
علينا نتذكر السياق هنا الامر لا يتعلق
بان الولايات المتحده هي التي
تسحب اثنين اصدقائها القريبين في كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان لكن ايضا علينا نتركن
هذين للبلدين تاريخيا كانت عندهم علاقات
صعبه وغير جيده والولايات المتحده اذا ما
نجحت فهي الشركه الرئيسي في هذا
لتحقيق هذه المظلمه الثقه التي يمكن ان
تولي لي يولد بها اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
خلافاتهم جانبا ليجتمعا على مبدا الثقه
الثقه بين البلدين ثقتهما بالولايات
المتحده وكل ذلك يقوم على فقدان الثقه ثقه
فقدان الثقه اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
الصين وبالتالي فمن جانب لدينا هذان
البلدان القويان
الديمقراطيتا ناجحتان واقتصاديا اقتصادات
الناجحه ينضمان انضمامه بعضهما بثقتهما
بالولايات المتحده وعدم الثقه في الصين
وهذا هو بالضبط هو سيحدث الخطوات التي
سيقوم بها وستكون مهمه جدا وهي اتفاق
بتشكيل التزام مجموعه
ملتزمه في حاله حصول اي هجوم او تصعيد
وهذا
ليشبه
للتحالف الذي تتحقق فيه كل الدول لوقوف
جنبها جنب الى جانب ضد اي صواريخ موجه
ضدها او ضد اي تمارين اذا كانت الرساله
السيد ادوارد وهنا سؤال لضيفي من بيجينا
السيد فيكتور جاو اذا كانت رساله هذه
القمه بهذا الوضوح
كيف ترى بيجين الى هذه الرساله وهذه القمه
التي تؤسس الى عهد جديد كما يقول تقول
الاطراف في هذه القمه قمه
على الاستضافه اعتقد ان ما يسمى
بالقمه هي ارسلت رساله خاطئه لماذا لانه
منذ عام 1953 عندما توصل
الحرب الكوريه كان هنالك سلام واستقرار في
شرق اسيا وهذه القمه حقيقه تساعد
العلاقات وتزيد من التوتر وتريد ان تستخدم
الوسائل العسكريه من اجل ان تقدم
لرساله تدعو الى الصراع والحرب فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في شرق اسيا هذه رساله خاطئه ايضا
هذه الرساله اتت في وقت حيكون هنالك ناس
في هاواي وماوي ما زالوا يعانون من هذه
الحرائق غير المسبوقه وهذا يعني ان
الحكومه الفيدراليه التي رات راسها الرئيس
بايدن لا يهتم بحياه الشعب
وهم في حقيقه الامر يركزون او تركز هذه
الاداره على تحقيق اهدافها عن طريق
الوسائل العسكريه اما في اوكرانيا مثلا او
حتى في انه خلقي توترنا في شرق اسيا حسب
هذه السياق وحسب السياقات الاصغر فان هذه
رساله خاطئه وخطيره اعتقد ان الشعوب شرق
اسيا عليها ان تستمر في دعم السلام
والاستقرار بدلا من ان تقع في هذا
التسابق
التسليح والدعوه الى الحرب بالتالي
الرساله خاطئه ولا ننسى هنالك اي شيء من
هذه القمه بامكانها ان يردع الناس والشعوب
في منطقتنا ان يلتزموا بالسلامه
والاستقرار بدلا من ان يقعوا في فخ الحرب
اعود كما عدت الى التاريخ واسال ضيفي
الدكتور خلعناني بالعوده الى التاريخ
بالتذكير منذ عهد اشهر وزير خارجيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كيسينجر وما طبع العلاقه الامريكيه
الصينيه تحت عنوان الغموض البناء في فهم
العلاقه الامريكيه تحديدا مما يتعلق
بموضوع تايوان ما الذي سيختلف عقب هذه
القمه برايك دكتور خليل
انا اعتقد اختلافات كثيره جدا عبد القادر
اولا نتكلم عن كما قلت قبل قليل تحالف
دفاع ثلاثي جديد هو اشبه بالنيته الذي
يعتبر اي اعتداء على دوله يعتبر اعتداء
على الدول الاخرى وبالتالي نحن ايذاء
تصعيد جديد في الوضع الاستراتيجي هناك
الامر الثاني سؤال مهم جدا لم يجب عليه
احد حتى هذه اللحظه ماذا سيحدث لو
قامت دول اخرى لهذا التحالف مثلا اذا قررت
امريكا في وقت من الاوقات ضم تايوان هذا
التحالف ماذا يعني هذا ضم الهند لدى
التحالف وبالتن نحن ازاء
يعني بدايه للتوتر قد يحدث لمنطقه قد يجد
على ما هو موجود بالفعل حاليا خاصه
وجود تحشيد ووجود توتر امريكي صيني على
قضايا مختلفه قضايا متعلقه بالتجاره
متعلقه بسباق التسلح متعلقه بالعلاقات بين
الصين وبالتالي كان المفترض ان يكون هناك
حوار اكثر من الدخول في شركات دفاعيه
مشكار رئيسيه انه نتكلم على وضع جديد تكون
في امريكا بشكل او باخر باحتواء الصين من
خلال من خلال القيام بتحالفات اقليميه
مثلا هناك تحالف مهم جدا
[موسيقى]
كما قال الضيف من بيجين فيما يتعلق بسعي
امريكا الحفيث لوجود نوع من التحالف
الثلاثي الدفاعي بالقطع موجه للصين من جهه
كما قلت قبل قليل وبالتالي الامر الذي حدث
اليوم لا يمثل للاسف تخفيض التوتر ما
بالعكس هو
من العالم بشكل او باخر
الدكتور ادوارد فيما يتعلق بالحاضر الغائب
في هذه القمه الروسيه تحديدا والعلاقه
الى حد الان وتحديدا بما يجري في اوكرانيا
هل نجحت واشنطن الى حد ما في تحييد الصين
عن طبيعه ما يجري في اوكرانيا خطوه هذه هل
لها ان تؤثر على هذه السياسه الامريكيه في
محاوله تحيد الصين عما يجري في اوكرانيا
لقد شاهدنا بان روسيا ومقامته من غسل مبرر
له قد
اثبت ان الصين هي
مزيفه فكل سياستها الداخليه والخارجيه
تقوم على مبدا السياده وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول الاخرى وطبعا الصين
تدعم روسيا في هجومها على اوكرانيا وسياده
اوكرانيا وهذا امر ادانته لامم الجمعيه
العام المتحده والدول الكثيره ولكن ليس
الصين وبالتالي فلسطين قد كشفت كانها
مزوره ومنافقه فتتحدث عن حمايه سياده
الاراضي الدول لكن عندما فقط عندما يتعلق
على مرض الصين وليس بدول اعضاء في مجلس
الامن وفي الامم الامم المتحده مثل
اوكرانيا وهذه ايضا يتعلق بالجيران الصين
لماذا نجد ان
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان ضمه
فيكتور وصفت قبل قليل هذه القمه وما نجم
عنها بانه خطوه خطيره وبالتالي باعتقادك
كيف ستتصرف بيجين حيال هذه الخطوه ثم دعني
استغل الفرصه مطرحه قبل قليل الدكتور خالد
العناني بالاشاره ماذا لو توسع هذا النيتو
الجديد الى دول اخرى الى الهند على سبيل
المثال او الى تايوان في هذه الحاله
في حقيقه الامر هذا سؤالا بالغ هي فيما
يتعلق بالسيد
ادوار جوازه اعتقدوا انما كان هناك الكثير
من الاخطاء في اجاباته بدايه كان بين
الصين تحترم سياده اوكرانيا لان الصين
تعتبر اوكرانيا انه عضو كامل في الامم
المتحده وبالتالي هي محميه بميثاق الامم
المتحده الصين لا تدعم طرفا على الاخر في
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا الصين حثت
الطرفين على ايقاف الحرب واستخدام الطرق
الدبلوماسيه والمفاوضات من اجل حل اي
مشكله لديهما بالتالي
مساله وصف الصين
وصف الصين كان خطا من قبل السيد جوزيف
وانا اريد ان اسال
اتحدى السيد جوزيف في ان يسير في ويتحدث
يسير في اي بلد مسلم وع لان لماذا هو لن
يتمكن ذلك لماذا لان الولايات المتحده لم
يهم يخشون اي امريكي لن يتمكن من السير في
تلك الشبراء لانه يخشون على حياتهم لان
الولايات المتحده قامت الكثير من الامور
من اجل
او لم تجبني على سؤالي كيف سترد الصين على
هذه الخطوه وماذا لو توسع هذا النيتو الى
دول اخرى كتايوان والهند باختصار لو تكرمت
مثل هذه المزاعم غير الحقيقيه في حقيقه
الامر طيب ساعود لك اذا تمكنا او منحنا
الوقت فرصه لاعود لك سيد
فيما يخص علاقه واشنطن قال البيت الابيض
ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مستعد للقاء
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون من
دون شروط مسبقه لمناقشه نزع السلاح النووي
في شبه جزيره الكوريه واضاف البيت الابيض
على لسان المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
انبيونج لم تستجب بشكل ايجابي لهذا العرض
لكنه لا يزال مطروحا على الطاوله وهنا
اسال الدكتور خليل العناني عن هذا العرض
من قبل اداره السيد بايدن للقاء الغير
مشروط مع رئيس كوريا الشماليه ماذا عن هذا
العرض في هذا التوقيت باعتقادك
انا لا اعتقد ان هذا عرض جدي او يمكن ياخد
الجديه صاحب القادر نحن فقط مجرد خطاب
امريكي ومتواجد منذ عقود يعني ليس الامر
جديد مع بيض ايضا كان هناك خطاب من اوباما
حدث الموضوع وبالفعل حدث اللقاء مع ترامب
لقاء شهير جدا وتاريخي بين ترامب وبين
رئيس كوريا الشماليه
استمرت كوريا الشماليه في نفس سلوكها فيما
يتعلق بقيام بتجارب صاروخيه نوويه في
متعلق بالتجارب والصاروخيه قد تصل في بعض
الاوقات الى اليابان وبالتالي هناك توتر
امريكي مع كوريا الشماليه قديم وجزء من
التوتر في رايي الشخصي متعلق بالتواجد
الامريكي الكثيف في تلك المنطقه من العالم
بنتكلم كما قلت قبل قليل على تمارين الف
جندي موجودون هناك منذ على الاقل سبعه
عقود منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه هذا
الامر يؤدي الى توترات موجوده لانه هذا
يعتبر الفناء خلفي
جندي صيني موجودين مثلا في المكسيك او في
كندا على حدود امريكا هذا الامر غير متصور
على الاطلاق وبالتالي ما يحدث الان هو
تكديس للتوترات زياده لها بشكل او اخر
وكما قلت قبل قليله بنتكلم على نوايا
الحلف دفاعي هو نواه نيتو اسيوي قد تنضمي
دول اخرى سواء كان تايوان او الهند او دول
حتى شرق اسيا كالفلبين طبعا حليف مهم جدا
لامريكا قد تنضم اليه مثلا في المستقبل
استراليا قد تنضم اليه ماليزيا واندونيسيا
بنتكلم على اعاده هيتكلم يطلق عليه الهيكل
الامني في منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا وشرق اسيا
وواحد الصين الجنوب هذا الامر ليس على
الاطلاق في صالح الهدوء العالمي او الامن
والسلم العالميين نحن ازاء مرحله جديده
نقطه جديده محطه جديده في التوتر من
العالم قد يؤدي في المستقبل سواء على
المدى المتوسط او المدى البعيد الى قد
يكون حرب او صراع مفتوح بين هذه الاطراف
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه بين الصين وبين
امريكا في المستقبل دكتور
ادوارد جوزيف في دقيقه لو تكرمت
هل حسابات هذا الحلف دقيقه عودتنا الصين
وكوريا الشماليه تقابل التصعيد بالتصعيد
وبالتالي ماذا عن هذه الخطوه التصعيديه
علق وجهه نظر بيجين وكذلك
شاهدنا مره اخرى فيما يتعلق بالسياسه
صينيه اذاعه كوريا الشماليه وايضا شاهدنا
النفاق
الصين
والتزويرها
عندما تكون للسلام والاستقرار اذا كانت
تريد الصين السلبي استقرار للتعاون مع
الولايات المتحده لاحتواء برنامج ناوي
لكوريا الشماليه ولكن الصين لا تفعل ذلك
وهذا واقع بل تريد ان تستغل هذا الوضع
وتقبل التعامل مع هذا البلد الاكثر خطرا
في العالم وهذا النظام الذي يستحي النوويه
ولا يتعاونون مع الولايات المتحده لاحتواء
برنامج
الكره الشمالي لان الصين تعلم ان ذلك يؤدي
الى عدم الاستقرار والصعوبات الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي في الصين مره اخرى تثبت
انها مزوره وزائفه من
فيكتور كيف ستتصرف الصين حيال هذه الخطوات
في دقيقه ونصف تكرمت
اعتقد ان الشيء الوحيد الذي ستقوم به
الصين هو دعوه كل الاطراف من ان تسعى نحو
السلم بدلا من تشجيع الحرب لانه فلسفيا في
عالم اليوم وخاصه في شرق اسيا فان الشيء
الصائب الوحيد لصالح كل الدول هو دعم
السلام وتشجيع عليه بدلا من تشجيع الحرب
اذا ما كان هنالك وقع في هذا الفخ سيكون
هنالك اضاعه للموارد وسيكون عليك سباق
لتسليح وايضا سيكون هنالك اجواء متوتره
وهو الامر الخاطئ وهو القرار الخاطئ
والاستراتيجيه الخاطئه والوجه الخاطئه
لهذا الجزء من العالم بالتالي فقط عن طريق
دعم السلام هذا هو الامر الصائب لنا جميعا
وان لكي قيام الولايات المتحده بمثل هذه
الامور هو الامر خاطئ وفي نهايه المطاف
سيكون فشلا ذريعا لها علينا ان نتذكر انه
خلال الحرب الكوريه كانت الصين ضد
مساله هذا هذه الجهود بلا تلمده وكان
هنالك هزيمه
والجيش الامريكي عليها ان لا ينسى الدرس
الذي تلقاه بعد هزيمته في حرب الكوريه
شكرا لك ادركنا الوقت ضيفي من بيجين
فيكتور جاو رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات
الدوليه وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من واشنطن
الدكتور ادوارد جوزيف استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه
وكذلك لضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور خليل استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]